non
oui
le principe d'un terreau surprise
gilbert dès ce vous allez voir des
questions qui concernent essentiellement
arnaud gidoin ici présent accord je les
adore bah enfin les vues dans le fusible
avec plaza formidable donc si vous
répondez correctement vous avez la
moyenne vous échapper aux gages qui sera
pendant la pub sur le facebook live est
le gage de d'aujourd'hui c'est de
remplacer eric autre chauffeur de salle
et de chauffer le public à blanc les bus
comment vous êtes méchants et vu comment
vous criez n'aura pas de problème je
sauve gagner ouais massa sûrs de gagner
ça m'étonnerait alors on a question vous
embêtez pas avec la cré est le cadeau à
chaque fois personne donc dans quelle
émission alliés par julien courbet
arnaud gidoin était-il chroniqueurs ça
commence bien
alors dans quelle émission animée par
julien courbet arnaud gidoin était-il
qu'est la réponse est oui sans aucun
doute
et bien sûr c'était donc en fait sans
aucun doute c'est ça c'est pas la
réponse que j'aimais
[Rires]
en toutes lettres sommes ici en tout cas
ça vous a marqué cette émission c'est
moi qui la voir un gars oui c'est la
crise en france
c'est dur parce que j'ai fait j'ai fait
des bêtises mis en avant avec gignac ont
bercé dans son jeu ça va bien je vais
prendre maintenant tout quand même bien
ça côté on est mal barré quand ma mort
allez on a des jeunes mais c'était pas
facile un extrait téléphone qui envoient
des bruits un sénoufo se dit une blague
n'importe quoi dans ce délai vous aimez
bien ça moi j'aime bien barreau me
demande souvent parce que je suis plutôt
de bonnes zones voilà j'en vois un peu
de bonnes secondes et puis je dis quand
même type quoique et puis j'aime bien
givet pourquoi je me priverais vous avez
raison pas là j'en ai payé si j'ai que
ça à [ __ ] c'est pour tenir le délai
trop attention deuxième question je
perdais vous avez zéro admis comme un
ennemi parce que rien du tout que dalle
il ya bientôt le bac si les élèves
répondent à à côté il rompt pas un
biberon
oui oui au bac et aucune question surgit
loin moi je te laisse le producteur de
la sitcom d'impro totale impro diffusée
sur m6 dans laquelle on retrouvait
notamment en premier rôle avec son
camarade foraine prévaut à un mot gidoin
est-ce que c'était ringard alors ça
c'est alors qu'est ce alors harraga oui
et non car c'est ben oui et non ça
m'aide pas ce que c'était un autre moi
je trouve pas donc c'était pas vous donc
c'est à dire laurent wauquiez nos
enfants n'ont pas de m6 mais non c'était
benjamin castaldi et oui les droits
comme eh oui on géo produisez ce
magnifique spectacle un spectacle sympa
c'est un adaptation de chirurgie trace
alors s'adapter au marché
oui c'est marrant moi y avait une mère
qui mais qui a bien gardé de ces deux
personnes citées ce n'était pas la bonne
programmation non non c'était vendredi
soir d'un jeune conducteur d'ailleurs je
crois à 2 heures du matin au
cartonnettes et ici blessés d'ailleurs
pendant cette émission je me suis
ouverte
j'avais commencé l'émission mais alors
là je peux pas vous dire mieux qu'un
accident toujours à zéro et que vous
êtes est un producteur à succès c'est
venons de vous à 0 sport un roman le nom
de mou je prends ça pour un compliment
si la chambre dans quelle émission at on
pu voir arnaud gidoin chanter en duo
avec elodie frégé là on va vous aider
tendez votre niveau catastrophique à
n'oubliez pas les paroles sur france 2 b
tout le monde chante sur w9 ou c'est de
cover sur aucune chaîne car ça a été un
four complet alors je dis jamais de le
répéter et de redire c'est pas du tout
un four ça fait amiantés du gâteau mais
oui c'est pas mal cyril bientôt leur
signature alors j'ai vu l'émission c à
n'oubliez pas les paroles a doublé à
bord
[Applaudissements]
monsieur
hier du mal j'ai des frissons je
l'emmène en déjouant de sang
le français
des musicales sont au dessus mais dans
le cendrier
[Applaudissements]
non c'est bien vous savez que c'était la
première chanson rap qui avait été
refusée par patrick bruel et du coup on
l'avait proposé en premier était assez
ancien pour les gens qui nous regardent
35 ans moi je devais avoir 15 ans quoi
14 épouse et moi je suis né je suis né
en 90 est donc clair pour aller vers des
travaux quatrième question attention
dans quelle émission diffusée
actuellement sur france 2 peut-on
retrouver arnaud arnaud
à noter doit alors je le regarde tous
les dimanches vivement dimanche avec
michel vaucaire mais vous êtes une
catastrophe en bleu en cours mais non
c'est pas ça
comment ça s'est passé à milan c'est
tout le monde a son mot à dire ouais
ouais
on voit que c'est vendredi qui a pas le
patron personnes à bord par contre je
profite qu ils soient debout j'ai jamais
vu quelqu'un entrer chemise autant dans
le pantalon domine
oui s'amuse parfois il nous arrive même
de vous autres de vous cacher avec tony
gay on se creuse les images away à
regarder est-il trop près de son oreille
renseignements merci
j'adore j'ai bouffé un tunnel on est sur
ces 8 mai vraiment olivier on attend
mais d'une bienveillante agwai alami
démission et elle mange de roy sports
j'embrasse sport est petit il vient
d'ailleurs d'en tuer un génial génial
l'émission était supprimée nagui est
intervenue une émission est finalement
sauvé ne va changer d'horaire sans doute
vers 17h40
si tu comptes jésus
il faut que la fin je me refais tante
qui tournait actuellement à montpellier
c'est qu'on a une info un tel menu de
toutes façons vous allez remplacer donc
eric pendant la pub et ce sera déposé
sur facebook live il faudra chauffer le
public déjà à l'idée de vous voir au
public est complètement éteint jeudi
mais c'est le faire attention où une
derrière sur la photo t ma nice il est
beau je vous en supplie
ça c'était la pub monsieur de fursac en
soi dans une idée at-il personnages de
dessins animés interprète arnaud gidoin
en est ce que ca
sami de scooby mais voilà b patrick de
bob l'eponge ou seedorf qui fait un
terreau direction répond sa famille de
scooby doo
ouais bonne réponse
malheureusement j il s'est perdu on a
les voies à votre place et vous aurez un
bonnet d'âne aussi bien battue n'a pas
du tout on a un petit extrait pas mal
regardé une future mine
je sais pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
stéphane plaza
oui pendant là il a il a su seulement
avant-hier que c'était pas moins que
c'est elle que j'étais en verre et pas
non plus pour tous non votre bras
pendant la pub sur le fait chauffer le
public
[Applaudissements]